it's time for a segment that is very
near and dear to my heart
drew's love bug that's right where we
explore
all things from dating behaviors all the
way to marriage and everything in
between
and today we're exploring how to find
love at every single age because guess
what you never
stop wanting to find love at any point
in your life
it's all about relationships and here to
help is certified dating coach
and friend of the show demona hoffman
hey drew hi damona
um i have some news for you i got a cute
fun text this weekend
and it just made me all a flutter it was
from like an
like a a missed opportunity if you will
but i was so
excited because i was like i'm not dead
i'm
actually like having a text exchange
and it was flirty and fun and
it made me feel alive and i couldn't
wait to share it with you damona
i love that news drew and you know when
we get these texts it it really boosts
our endorphins and it gives us
hope in finding love so i'm really
excited to be here today and help find
love for some other folks at all
different ages because
you can always find love i've had
clients all the way from 20 all the way
to 70.
so we can really we can really do
something with these folks today well
also this was a text
which means like i got like a tech
butterfly
and you said my favorite thing ever
which is i was like we want
old-fashioned romance and you were like
if you can drop the digital hanky
and i was like i got like an
old-fashioned feeling from a modern text
and
so i know that people can be weary about
dating apps especially
if they're a little older because it's
not the way they grew up and change is
scary
so listen we're going to get into that
in a second our first vff is michelle
what is your question for demona hi drew
hi damona
um i've been dating for probably about
the last three years
and everyone knows me as the resident
cougar
i love dating you men i normally date
between the ages of 28 and 35.
i don't know what it is i think it's
because i'm outgoing
i'm active i ride motorcycles i don't
have
any problems meeting younger men um i'm
just not attracted to older men
but lately i haven't had any luck with
the younger men so
how do i go about finding an older man
who will
excite me and keep up with me just as
much as a younger man
well i would say first props for being
confident and i love that cougar life
and i believe that aj nothing but a
number okay michelle
so i'll just turn that around on you
that
you could find someone who you're
attracted to
who is older it's it's all about having
the right mindset and being
where the right kind of single guys
are so for you i would say you can
get really creative with the way that
you search on dating apps
i'll give you a little hot tip that i
that i share with some of my clients
a keyword search a keyword search in
some of the legacy dating apps you can
look by
interest you can look by commonalities
because really it's not just about the
age it's about finding someone
who has the same energy level to do the
things that you enjoy doing
who has shared values of course and then
common goals for the future
and that's probably where you're running
into a little bit of friction with the
younger
men because they're not on the same life
path
that you are so i would say try the
keyword search and also
i'll give you a story about the keyword
search i had a client
who was same age as you are and she was
looking for love online and
she also she loved motorcycles had an
active lifestyle
i told her to do a keyword search on
match
for motorcycles and she ended up meeting
a guy last year and they just got
married in august so i know that this
works if it worked for her it could
totally work for you
you too your love lesson is just to to
stay
open to the possibility that you might
meet someone
of your own age and they as long as they
enjoy the same things that you do and
they
are looking towards the future in the
same way that you are it can absolutely
work
and i have two words for you michelle
vroom vroom
a b demona that is such a hot tip to put
in keywords
of interests i love this no one has ever
said that to me
or around me i'm into that michelle i
hope that helps that's
really exciting and by the way why do
you like younger guys like is it like an
ego thing like you're like
oh if i'm you know i feel younger around
younger men because i personally am like
i'm not ready to diaper you you're too
young get out
i want someone who is at my place in
life which is definitely
like older or is it really like i want
to have
fun and when guys are older they're just
a little more calm and relaxed and i'm
really looking to like
do it up and live like there's no
tomorrow
well i feel like well i'm 51 and i i
feel like
men my age they just want to just sit
around watch tv like i
i want to get out uh i run 5ks every
month i ride my motorcycle
i do home improvement projects so i'm
just trying to find somebody who will
has the same interest and will keep up
with me um
and i don't know there's just something
about younger men um
i just find a drive too well then i
think you need some key
search words no couch potato and someone
full of chutzpah
yeah you can also meet someone out
michelle
there's other ways like you can be doing
social distance meetups
you can also look for groups on facebook
of common interest
so it's really about finding someone
that's your speed
and your style not so much about the age
i would say
i'm with demona age is totally a number
i just
like you're right i demonia you're
perfectly right my mom always used to
say that
she would meet younger people who were
kind of acted older and older people who
were immature
so it is really about the spirit well i
wish you the best of luck and i hope
you're
got the wind in your hair and some
fabulous
like stallion who doesn't want to just
sit on the couch all day
that's what you want that's what you
should get okay thank you ladies
well michelle thank you because i really
love talking about all this stuff and
demona you are the best partner in crime
for this stuff
because we are always searching for
relationships we are always working on
relationships this is something
that we will do until we move on because
that's what life is about
you know figuring out everything within
ourselves but
also contending with other people we
want we're communal
we're looking for love we want to work
on this stuff and to mona i'm so lucky i
get to do this with you because i just
love all the things you say
oh thank you the feeling is absolutely
mutual drew
and i was excited to tell you i had a
flirty text
it was amazing i was like i have a
heartbeat this is exciting
you